christian mary calix bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidat aux élections
municipales dans la commune du gros
morne
vous avez présenté il y à peu un c'était
le 24 novembre dernier
votre candidature votre projet pour le
gros morne mais donné dit nous d'abord
christian mary calixte qu'est ce qui
vous a motivé à vous présenter en tête
de liste voilà ce qui m'a motivé c'est
tout simplement un 2004 j'étais candidat
mais compte tenu de la multiplicité des
candidatures
j'ai préféré supporter la liste sortante
de madame et il est et ce qui me motive
aujourd'hui c'est parce que je vois que
ma commune la liste sortante de madame
et idées dites vous oui madame nathalie
était allée elle était sortante avec
l'équipe de monsieur albert joséphine
d'accord donc en 2014 de l'éducation de
2014 s'y passe est pas celle qui va être
sur scène non pas celle de monsieur
couturier n'a pas du tout non mais voilà
donc on est bien alors continuer moi je
voulais avoir cette précision d'accord
alors ma motivation c'est que
aujourd'hui j'ai constaté que je ne dis
pas que j'ai supporté monsieur produits
mais le connaissant je savais que
c'était un homme d'action
mais durant sa mandature j'ai pas vu ces
actions là notre commune est dans un
état où aujourd'hui jeudi qu' il faut
absolument sortir dans la commune dans
cet espace d'accord alors mais
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui vous donnez
nous un exemple qui vous fait dire
justement que la commune et au cours de
ces six dernières années quasiment
finalement se retrouvent
dans l'impasse aujourd'hui moi il ya la
dette du goût moi que j'ai vu assez
rapidement que je connais finalement les
2 6 millions d'après ce que je sais il
ya aussi l'investissement ya rien eu
comme investissement bon j'ai eu les
projets de monsieur couturier qu'il m'a
dit que c'est un coup le stade l'église
la zone artisanale de petites écoles et
puis à rien mais rien n'a été fait
pendant sa mandature beaucoup pour vous
ce n'est pas allé assez vite
pas assez vite je suis pas sûr de ce
qu'il m'a dit dans les projets à venir
mais non mais là là au cours des six
dernières années il n'ya rien n'y a rien
eu donc voilà c'est même pas que c'est
même pas aller assez vite il n'y a pas
eu suffisamment quoi voilà et gharyane a
rien fait autre constat d'accord on a
bien compris
alors christian mary calixte si vous
arrivez donc aux affaires à la tête de
la municipalité gros mornais zh en mars
prochain quel serait votre dossier
numéro un
votre priorité la priorité c'est déjà
fait l'audit de l'état des finances de
la ville
ensuite convoqué le personnel pour
mobiliser le personnel et les orienter
vers des actions qui permettent de
fructifier la vie de la commune mais je
vais pas fait de dit du personnel parce
que c'est un personnel compétent que je
connais et je vais convoquer chaque
personne pour savoir lorsque way élus ou
à mobiliser le personnel
alors parmi vos projets je crois vous
avez
alors au gros-morne effectivement
d'ailleurs vous dites que vous voulez
redonner à cette ville du gros-morne un
petit peu son un rôle qu'elle avait
avant qui était finalement d'être l'un
des greniers de la martinique 1 en
quelque sorte donc de nourrir la
population donc voulait relancer un peu
toute l'activité pas seulement en
général mais agricole wind economics
économistes oui comme j'ai dit j'ai dix
points d'appui qui paul de la santé le
développement économique l'aménagement
du territoire et aussi le développement
agricole ya plusieurs secteurs dans la
gauche dure et aujourd'hui au goût moi
que j'ai fait un pôle excellence rurale
parce qu'il ya des finances comme ça et
puis ou à donner ou à dynamiser la ville
un pôle d'excellence rurale qu'est ce
que ça apporterait de plus selon vous
pour le gros morne et aider sa
population quand j ai pôle excellence
rurale c'est l'excellence d'un tout
parce qu'il ya des financements la loi
estrosi en 2005 permettaient d'avoir des
finances à raison d'un million avec les
partenaires publics privés et puis aussi
aux gones je vais surtout on voit le
plus le flanc le plan local d'urbanisme
qui a pénalisé pas mal de familles ou
aux moines
et puis pour finir oui ce qu'on finira
l'installation d'une dizaine d'éoliennes
sur le territoire qui va ramener un taxe
professionnelle une somme assez aux
alentours d'un million à la belugo mois
christian romaric alix merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
on vous souhaite une très bonne journée
merci